there's no neutrality this is something
we've talked about on the show a lot
there's no neutrality in speech there's
no neutrality in politics there's no
neutrality in the physical world you've
always got to be doing something the
question is what are you doing are you
spending time playing with your kids are
you spending time working building up a
business are you spending time fixing up
the house or are you spending time
loafing around and you know just getting
drunk and and indulging your lusts there
was an article that showed that there
were apparently hundreds and hundreds of
high-class prostitutes who are
descending on on Davos for the
conference are you what are you doing if
anybody needs to remain more occupied
not less I think it is those Elites